hey david you talked about right-wing
dog whistles are there
left-wing dog whistles this is an
interesting question remi
you know when we talk about a dog
whistle a dog whistle
is a coded message that's communicated
by using words or phrases or even
gestures in some way
that are commonly understood by a
particular group of people and not
necessarily by others
so as an example a george soros
and roth the rothschilds that has become
a dog whistle for
anti-semitic tropes about rich usually
jewish men
conspiring to control elements of
government or banking or whatever the
case may be the recent marjorie taylor
green
jewish space laser incident when she
says the rothschilds that
is a dog whistle for people who are
primed
about uh jewish conspiracies to control
this or that industry
to understand that by rothschilds you're
really talking about jews
george soros often when it's mentioned
it means
jews and so that would be example of a
right-wing
dog whistle people some people are
attuned
to listen to it listen for it or to hear
it
globalist is another one which often
also is used to signal we're talking
about
jews now i have some examples of left
wing
maybe what we would call dog whistles
they're pretty lame and
they really don't rise to the level of
the right wing dog whistles the right
uses dog whistles
much more than the left here's a couple
of examples i could think of
sometimes when the left says rural
you could argue that it's a sort of dog
whistle for
like the uneducated hillbilly meme
or caricature sometimes not not always
um sometimes there's dog whistling
around suggesting people are racist like
for example
saying someone voted for the crime bill
talking about the 90s crime bill
that could be a pseudo dog whistle to
imply someone is
is racist without saying this is a
racist person
um maybe flyover country
is a dog whistle to suggest that
you know kind of the center of the
country is less
than the so-called liberal coastal areas
the reason that these are kind of weak
is because the left really doesn't
use language in the dog whistle way
that the right does for better or worse
and when i say for worse
we know that the left is terrible at
branding
and to some degree even though the dog
whistling on the right is disgusting in
many cases including stuff like soros
as a catch-all for for jews some of the
dog whistling the right does has been
very effective politically
when it comes to um uh abortion when it
comes to some
religious ideas when it comes to
taxation there are dog whistles
that the right has used successfully i
think they're disgusting and inaccurate
they relate to socialism and life and
all these different things
but the reason that the examples i'm
coming up with for the left uh um
the reason that those are lame uh is
that
the left really just doesn't use
language in this way and to some degree
the left has suffered for it the left
has probably
lost what could have been wins in some
cases
because their branding and language is
is not as uh
finely tuned finally operating of a
machine
as the writers if you can think of
left-wing dog whistles
that i've missed certainly let me know
we've got a fantastic bonus show for you
today get instant access to the bonus
show
by becoming a member at joinpackman.com